okay how about a hand for my partner
here but we press them into serve it's
okay you had a question for the governor
you said you wanted to know climate
change which is going to destroy
everything we know and love animal
agriculture is the third leading cause
of climate change but when I asked Al
Gore about it he said that the role of
animal agriculture and climate change is
the true Inconvenient Truth
and I hear almost no enough right at
cop21 about yeah I did my part today I
had an excellent impossible burger yeah
they're getting good yeah yeah and we
got to look for new options
scientifically to look at those things
it is an important issue I think we need
to engage the agricultural industry to
figure out there's a way to sequester
carbon in topsoil and trees so that we
can get carbon out of the atmosphere to
do it and then we got a cheer up bill
who seems to be a little down right now
bill I just want to give you some good
news I've now sued Donald Trump 21 times
and I'm 21 and oh I just sued he sued me
once and I want to know okay what are
your thoughts on Trump's recent attacks
on abortion will Roman versus Wade be
upheld if challenged that's kind of a
bummer Kara why is the EU more willing
to take action against big tech than the
United States yeah because the person
doing it is a woman who has a lot of
backbone
[Applause]
different ideas about privacy in Europe
as opposed to here the same thing in
Australia and New Zealand in other
places okay we'll see Brett why do you
find Bernie Sanders so threatening to
democracy is he as bad as Trump well I
think a guy who took his honeymoon in
the Soviet Union praised Castro praised
Ortega and in Nicaragua those guys are
dictators who have been repressing human
rights in their countries for ages
shouldn't be President shouldn't be the
standard bearer for the Democratic Party
and they said nobody nobody says
capitalism is a perfect system nobody
says that we can't fix it but the idea
that we want to go to something that
looks like the economies of Europe today
where unemployment is 10% I don't think
that's that's a winner for the United
States at all good answer
answer the question though bluntly no
Bernie Sanders is not as bad as okay
Moby deep musicians have a
responsibility to use their platforms to
influence politics that ends what type
of music they're playing if they are
inbred Republicans playing
country-western and by all means they
should not be politically engaged of
course I mean it helps it I'm like
similar to you like single income no
kids no family so like the fact that I
have no accountability to anyone gives
me as sort of like like I'm at liberty
to be involved in politics for like if
someone had like kids and family I can
understand them wanting to sort of like
protect their career more but it does
seem like in a different era more
musicians felt the responsibility to
speak out about matters that matter in
the world as opposed to now when you
don't hear a lot of it you know here I
mean it's very light and it's it's very
it doesn't seem odd to me that people
prioritize other issues I feel like the
music is low-energy I feel like it's all
sound like
yeah okay who would you have wanted
present what would you have wanted
President Trump to say to Putin during
their phone call today no well like
anything a traitor would you like like
this we just got a big report from the
Muller team it took over two years and
the one thing that they said that was
the big headline was you definitely
interfered in our last election if you
do it again there will be serious
serious content about that's what I
would like that's what any president
again you did it
right so after your assets and we're
gonna go after the talking G's on your
entire financial so that things actually
hurt you for a change of their concept
what would you do what would you do if
you were running against anybody in a
Democratic field or a Republican
opponent in China or Russia came to you
and said we found them with a baby goat
or they've had some incriminating
evidence against them doing something
what would you what's the what's the
thing that you should do I would put
down the phone and I would call the
Federal Bureau of sedition there's no
excuse for otherwise and I think the the
fact that here is we got hung up and
Donald Trump is hid behind this word of
collusion in it as a false camouflage
for the fact that he welcomed wanted and
asked for the intrusion of the Russian
nation in our interference he did it on
live television and he is now hid behind
this word the one rule of traitor Club
is you're not mean to your handler right
yeah and by the way besides doing great
things for the environment if we got off
oil a little side beneficiary of that
what would it do kill Putin yeah he gets
all his money from oil but you just got
a whole [ __ ] ton of oil we get off oil
Russia has no money to [ __ ] around in
the world you know the governor made
such
look the problem isn't what Trump may
have done behind closed doors it's what
he does in public every single day it's
like you don't have to go and get a room
when you're having sex in a convertible
on Sunset Boulevard in broad daylight
like everyone can see what is going
something what is going on just aspiring
mrs. Robinson this conversation is
getting awkward
[Applause]
you